[Music]
racing to escape Sudan on this Wednesday
night it was quite horrific the
harrowing rescues and the Canadians
still waiting is our military about to
help as Sudan Teeters on the edge of
Civil War
Hawks bucks and politics let's get her
done the billion dollar promise to
replace Calgary's Saddle Dome on the
ease of an election
alarming shortage you truly are facing a
crisis Canada's critical need for family
doctors
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with the thousands of people
waiting to be rescued from the fighting
in Sudan among them hundreds of
Canadians the government says it is
assisting 700 Canadians there about 180
of them have been airlifted by our
allies Canada's defense minister said
today military planes and troops are in
the region ready to go in China got
people out by boat Greece has flown out
some of its citizens the UK has
airlifted hundreds of people to safety
the UK Germany France and the U.S have
all sent in military planes we'll look
at Canada's slower response in just a
moment but first Mike drolet on what's
happening on the ground right now
the race to get out of Sudan is down to
the wire with the window closing on a
three-day ceasefire
the first planes filled with elated yet
traumatized evacuees have begun Landing
throughout Europe it's difficult to say
how
stomach churning it was Vesna vukovic a
Canadian teacher Global News spoke with
on the weekend just arrived in Egypt
that was a hard journey we're filthy
hungry and completely dehydrated she
says she along with other Canadians
spent 72 hours crammed into a bus after
global Affairs Canada informed them no
air evacuations were possible the
Canadian government has since leaned on
its allies and just today announced a
pair of Canadian c-130s are preparing to
enter Sudan the Canadian Armed Forces
are ready to begin conducting evacuation
flights and will do so once conditions
on the ground permit
meanwhile Anarchy and Chaos reign in
hakthoum complicating matters even more
Ahmed Haroon a leader of the regime
deposed in 2019 who's wanted for war
crimes has escaped from jail and now the
International Community is rushing to
say itself and leaving the Sudanese
people in the hands of these warned
sides calls from the International
Community for an end to the fighting
have been ignored leaving Sudan on the
brink of Civil War a humanitarian crisis
is in the offing in front of our eyes
and only a combined United Nations
African Union intubation would solve
would help save up a crisis
neighboring countries have already seen
tens of thousands of Sudanese refugees
cross their borders and the conflict
isn't even two weeks old microwave
Global News Toronto
our Ottawa bureau chief Mercedes
Stevenson is with me Mercedes U.S
Special Forces went into Sudan three
days ago where is Canada's military and
our special forces
Donna the Canadian military says a task
force has deployed to the nearby African
country of Djibouti it is comprised of
both members of the elite and secretive
Canadian Special Operations forces and
troops from first Canadian division
they're tasked with evacuating Canadian
citizens from Sudan more troops are also
on route from third Royal Canadian
regiment based at CFB Petawawa as Canada
has finally arrived in the region in
recent days there is frustration in the
Canadian national security and defense
establishment over the speed at which
political decisions have been made
contrary to the government's assertion
the conflict came out of left field
high-level National Security sources say
the government was warned about the
deteriorating situation in Sudan and the
possible need to evacuate three weeks
ago through Canadian liaison officers
working at U.S Africa command those
sources say Canada had both the
contingency plans and the necessary
military equipment to pre-position for
evacuations of our citizens at that time
as did many of our allies Donna okay
Mercedes Stevenson in Ottawa thanks the
head of the federal Public Service Union
wants the prime minister to get involved
in strike negotiations and accuses the
government of stalling on the talks the
strike has gone on for eight days now
today the treasury board president
called some of the Union's demands
unaffordable but insists the government
remains at the negotiating table David
Aiken reports
shut it down shut it down day eight of
the strike and on the picket line a
heightened sense of frustration and even
anger at the government I think people
are getting
from waiting this long I mean it's
expensive for us I think they're
definitely going to try to drain us out
get us tired
um I can yeah absolutely I can see that
happening but again we're here every day
still showing up but there is some
frustration on the government side too
yes it's frustrating to know that
Canadians may as the days come have more
difficulty accessing services but that's
a motivator for everyone to try and
resolve this the union is certainly very
aware of Canadians impatience and they
have to calibrate that carefully calling
on the Prime Minister now the union says
it has moved a little on outstanding
wage issues though it wouldn't give us
details the government says it is
sticking to its offer of a nine percent
raise over three years which it believes
is as much as the taxpayer can afford
right now but that offer is not good
enough and that seems to be where the
negotiations are stuck at this point one
final note so far no indication that the
government is contemplating Back To Work
legislation and you know even if they
wanted to do that tomorrow because of
the rules around parliamentary procedure
the earliest any such legislation could
be debated would be next week Donna
David there's been talk that some people
out on strike might still be getting
paid what's going on with that I asked
the minister in charge of the
government's payroll system about this
very issue today and here's what she
said employees that continue to offer
services will be paid and those that are
on strike will not see that pay on their
next page check so members of the
Striking Union who are essential workers
and are still on the job they will get
paid but those off the job will not get
paid even though they are getting paid
today for a pay period that ended two
weeks ago before the strike started
Donna okay David thanks the federal
government has begun its long promised
Firearms buyback program the first phase
will focus on 11 000 assault style
firearms and components in the inventory
of retailers across the country as
Mackenzie gray explains the government
is still working to hit its Target on
tougher gun control
it's phase one of his signature liberal
promise it is an important reflection of
our government's commitment to make good
on a promise around the launch of a
program that will get assault-style
Firearms which were designed for a
battlefield out of our communities once
and for all that program and agreement
with the Canadian Sporting Arms and
ammunition Association to help the feds
buy back certain firearms and other
accessories from retailers and
Distributors guns the Liberals
prohibited in May 2020 after the mass
shooting in Nova Scotia these are the
first assault-style Firearms bought back
under the program but the government's
own partner says they're skeptical of
the plan with the CSAA pointing out
there are no concrete processes or a
budget for buying back the estimated 11
000 guns impacted by this measure what
you see here it looks meaner right and
finding a store that still has these
items in stock might be a challenge I
sold everything before the law so I
don't have anything in stock right now
even for the handguns the demand was so
big we sold everything in store
conservatives believe the liberal plan
misses the Mark it's not one
legal gun will be taken off the streets
by mendocino's announcement today
but Advocates note it's legal guns that
have been used in tragedies like
polytechnique and the Quebec mosque
attack most mass shootings in Canada are
bilingual gun owners or with guns that
were at one time legally owned the next
step for the Liberals expanding the
buyback program to individuals but
they'll need to act quickly Donna the
amnesty order for Canadians who own
restricted Firearms expires on October
30th
Mackenzie gray in Ottawa thank you fans
of the Calgary Flames got something new
to cheer about last night or at least
the promise of something new after the
last deal for a new Arena collapse
there's a new agreement in principle to
replace the Saddle Dome the price tag is
more than doubled to 1.2 billion dollars
the majority of that would be paid for
with public money from the city in the
province and as Heather urich's West
reports one person making the promises
hoping it will help her get elected
Premier next month
the Saddle Dome an iconic landmark
that's perhaps past its prime the
Calgary Flames have been after a new
home for years and after many failed
attempts it seems the NHL team has found
public money to help pay for it
this entertainment Hub will feature a
new event center and a community Arena
along with critical infrastructure
required to support growth and
development the city will pay the
largest share of the Project's 1.22
billion dollar cost promising 537
million or 44 percent the Flames
ownership group will kick in 356 million
while the province will pay 330 million
those provincial dollars will go towards
infrastructure around the center as well
as to cover the costs of tearing the
Aging Saddle Dome down but there's a
catch those funds won't be approved
until after the Alberta election next
month
that's why on May 29th I'm hoping
calgarians give our UCP government a
clear mandate to proceed with this Arena
deal
with the Writ about to drop this
memorandum of understanding was brokered
just in time for an election that will
be won or Lost based on how Calgary
votes it's critical uh the the math in
Alberta Politics the UCP will have much
of rural Alberta locked up the NDP have
most of Edmonton locked up the NDP will
need to pick up at least 15 seats 10 to
15 seats in Calgary to be knocking at
the door of government
still subsidizing Arenas is rare in
conservative policy and when Edmonton
was seeking provincial support for
Roger's Place Daniel Smith opposed the
use of public funds during the 2012
Alberta race but it seems this is a
different city a different year heading
into a very different campaign Heather
your ex West Global News Calgary
coming up how a Chinese attack on Taiwan
could grind the global semiconductor
sector to a halt
jailed Russian opposition leader Alexei
navalny says he's facing new extremism
and terrorism charges that could keep
him behind bars for life
appeared by a video link from a penal
colony where he's being held the
pre-trial hearing lasted several minutes
it's the first time he's been seen in
months Nevada said a new Criminal Case
on terrorism charges has been opened
against him which he says could land him
in prison for another 30 years he's
already facing 11 and a half years on a
range of charges which his supporters
say are trumped up
the Ukrainian President Vladimir
zielinski and the Chinese president Xi
Jinping spoke by phone today their first
Contact since Russia's full-scale
invasion of Ukraine zielinski says the
hour-long conversation was meaningful
she called on all sides to reflect on
the situation and says he would send a
special Envoy to Keith to serve as a
mediator China has declared itself
neutral in Russia's war with Ukraine but
she has not hidden his close ties with
President Vladimir Putin nor has he
condemned his offensive Ukraine had been
asking to speak with China since she's
State visit to Moscow last month
there is one component most of us take
for granted in Modern Life the
semiconductor they are the chips that
power everything from mobile phones to
electric cars and the majority of them
are made in one place Taiwan as Jeff
Semple reports that means if China ever
invades Taiwan it could trigger a global
economic meltdown
this Taiwanese robotics lab offers a
glimpse into the Future these arms
equipped with artificial intelligence
and 3D cameras can in effect see what
they're doing because our robot have
eyes her vision so they can do great
offers this unit tasks from separating
recycling to creating computer
motherboards and perhaps their most
important job is helping to build
semiconductors
so important that in the modern world we
cannot live without it these tiny
computer chips are the brains of modern
Electronics powering everything from
fridges to fighter jets the
semiconductor now is like an air you
know to to the human being so it's
everywhere and your camera your car and
your cell phone your washing machine
your refrigerator and not just for the
daily life also for the security of
defense for every Nations this small
island nation is a technological giant
Taiwan produces 65 percent of the
world's chips and almost 90 percent of
its Advanced chips but growing tensions
with Beijing could threaten that
semiconductor Supply
if the Chinese military were to invade
Taiwan as U.S intelligence says it's
preparing to do the semiconductor sector
could grind to a halt the seven
Continental supply chain is fragile this
analyst Works in taiwan's Sinju Science
Park home to the industry's biggest
names and Manufacturing facilities he
says about a third of materials required
for Semiconductor production have no
other source if any Invasion happened
then probably the the all the traffic
will be blocked the consequence will be
very serious because the world cannot
react that quickly the world got a small
taste of a semiconductor shortage during
the pandemic soaring demand for work
from home electronics caused a supply
crunch for smartphones and cars
electric vehicles require more than
twice as many chips as internal
combustion engines one of many emerging
Technologies further fueling our chip
addiction Canada has a significant role
to play in the semiconductor industry
countries including Canada the US and
China are scrambling to boost their
domestic semiconductor Supply but have a
long way to go take semiconductor
industry in Taiwan it takes almost more
than 50 years it's not like overnight
you can all of a sudden make it happen
China is the world's largest consumer of
semiconductors but produces less than 20
percent of its own most of its chips are
made in Taiwan some believe that
protects the Taiwanese from Attack
what's been dubbed the Silicon Shield
this has been a godsend for Taiwan if
there were armed conflict in the Taiwan
Strait either an attempted Invasion or
even a a blockade immediately you would
see repercussions in the trillions of
dollars for the global economy taiwan's
greatest hope for preventing an invasion
may also be the smallest Jeff simple
Global News Taipei
a Taiwanese Island that sits even closer
to Mainland China could become caught in
the middle of a conflict tomorrow Jeff
explains why its residents fear being on
the front line of a brutal War
a dire shortage of family doctors ahead
what's making the job less attractive to
medical students
every year medical students in Canada
get matched with residency positions to
train in the medical field they've
chosen it is stressful competitive and
there are multiple rounds and now a
record number of residents are choosing
not to work in Family Medicine leaving
hundreds of spots vacant Catherine Ward
explains why that is Raising concerns
you truly are facing a crisis in Family
Medicine count yourself lucky if you
have easy access to a family doctor our
most recent data shows over 2.2 million
ontarians don't have a family physician
and I think what's really concerning
about that number is it's actually
increased from 1.8 million in the two
years prior data from the Canadian
resident matching service indicates
Family Practice is not a Top Choice for
many in the next generation of medical
Physicians this year in the first round
nearly one in five family doctor
positions went unfilled in the Resident
matching process vacancies and Family
Practice accounted for three-quarters of
all unmatched spots experts hope more
students will match into the field in
round two as medical students expand
their options there are many reasons why
a match does not happen they may have a
very limited application uh profile they
only apply to four or five locations and
maybe only one discipline and go those
disciplines might be very high demand
Family Physicians say the job can be a
hard sell citing administrative burdens
and stress about 57 percent of family
doctors experiencing symptoms of burnout
leaving those on the front line bearing
the brunt of the shortage one of the
challenge in the trickle-downs is the
fact that when people don't have timely
access to their primary care provider
people use emergency services to get
care whether it's renewing prescription
maintenance of chronic care and diseases
that just go unchecked there is hope
that many of these family residency
positions will be filled in the second
round of matching on Thursday and that
doctors who do choose Family Practice
stick it out for the long term Family
Physicians to do the job well need to
operate in teams with nurse
practitioners with physician assistants
with dietitians with physios it needs to
cognitively offload the burden the
paperwork so that we can get them to do
what they're good at which is take care
of patients Catherine board Global News
Toronto
into a king to Mark the coronation of
King Charles on May the 6th the British
team has created a sweet life-size bust
of him it's all made of chocolate more
than 17 liters of it it took 130 hours
to make over the course of four weeks it
weighs 23 kilograms and is embellished
with Twix Milky Way galaxy and Bounty
bars the metals include Snickers
apparently it's the uniform Charles is
expected to wear on his coronation day
Global News will have special coverage
of that day the king's coronation on May
6 I'll be in London at 5 a.m Eastern 2
A.M Pacific right here on global and
that is global national for this
Wednesday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's
your Canada is the Science World dome in
Vancouver we'd love to see your Canada
please email it to viewers at
globalnational.com thanks for watching
hope to see you here again tomorrow
bye-bye
[Music]
thank you